Earlier when you talked about
criminality and creativity trends in,
uh,
in men peaking at 14,
it reminded me of something you said,
I think it was Joe Rogan.
I'm talking with sjws and kind of in how
they create their own chaos,
talking about how adolescents have this
drive to change the world.
And I was wondering if,
uh,
if those three,
the criminality,
creativity drive to change the world are
linked and if so,
if they manifest differently in men and
women and if they couldn't have come
from the same.
I think they are linked.
But I'm going to concentrate more on the
second part of your question.
So I'm going to ask you about something.
So I talked to a friend of mine the
other day.
He's a very,
very smart guy and we've been talking
about all the sorts of things that we've
been talking about tonight for a long
time.
And we were talking about the relatively
the relative evolutionary roles of men
and women.
This is speculative obviously.
And and because our research did
indicate it's tended of research so far
that,
that the,
the,
the SGS sjw sort of equality above all
else philosophy is more prevalent among
women,
what it's predicted by the personality
factors that are more common among
women,
so agreeableness and high negative
emotion,
primarily agreeableness.
But in addition it's also predicted by
being female.
And that's interesting because in most
of the personality research that I've
done and as far as I know in the
literature at,
you know,
in more broadly speaking,
most of the time you can get rid of the
attitudinal differences between men and
women or at least reduce them by
controlling for personality.
So if you take a feminine man in a
masculine woman,
then you know the polls reverse.
But that didn't seem to be the case with
political correctness.
And so I've been thinking about that a
lot because,
well,
men are bailing out of the humanities
like mad and pretty much out of the
universities except for step,
the women are moving in like mad and
they're also moving into the political
sphere like Matt and this is new,
right?
We've never had this happen before and
we do.
No,
no.
Do not know what the significance of it
is.
It's only 50 years old and so we were
thinking about this and so I don't know
what you think about this proposition,
but imagine that,
that,
that historically speaking at something
like women were responsible for
distribution and men were responsible
for production,
something like that.
And maybe maybe that's only the case
really in the tight confines of the
immediate family,
but that doesn't matter because that's
most of the evolutionary landscape for
human beings anyways.
But the women does it did was make sure
that everybody got enough.
Okay.
And that seems to me to be one of the
things that's driving,
at least in part,
the sjw demand for,
for equity and equality.
It's like,
let's make sure everybody has enough.
well look,
fair enough.
You know,
I mean,
you,
you can't,
you can't argue with that,
but there's,
there's an antipathy between that and
the reality of differential productivity
because people really do differ in their
productivity.
So.
All right,
so to answer your question fully,
I do think that the rebellious tendency
of adolescents is associated both with
that criminality spike,
especially among men and with
creativity.
Yes.
I think that the sjw phenomena is
different and I think it is associated
at least in part with the rise of women
to political power and and we don't know
what women are like when they have
political power because they've never
had it.
I mean there's been queens obviously and
that sort of thing.
Just being female authority figures and
females have wielded far more power
historically than feminists generally
like to admit,
but this is a different thing and we
don't know what,
what truly female political philosophy
would be like,
but it might be,
especially if it's not been well
examined and it isn't very sophisticated
conceptually.
It could easily be,
but let's make sure things are
distributed equally well.
Yeah,
but sorry that that's just not gonna
fly.
Do you think in terms of the west with
sjws and you talked about last lecture
as well,
creating chaos when there is none.
Otherwise it'd be Sadek.
Do you think there would be any validity
in saying that in a country like Canada
where we're pretty gender equal,
is there any merit to thinking sjws are
trying to create chaos even when they're
arguably is none on a mass level?
Obviously there's still problems.
Why would they do that?
Otherwise it would be static.
Well it wouldn't,
but I'm just wondering is this,
I read this quote once and I don't
remember who,
who said it,
it might've been Robert Heinlein for
crying out loud science fiction author
that springs to mind,
but it probably,
it probably wasn't.
And the proposition was that man tested
ideas and women tested men and I kind of
liked that.
There's something about that,
you know,
and now it obviously it's an
overgeneralization,
but we also don't know to what degree
women test men.
Surely through provo provocation it's a
lot because like if you want to test
someone,
you don't have a little conversation
with Mike,
you poke the hell out of them and you
see,
okay,
like I'm gonna like go after you and see
where your weak spots are.
And it seems to me that this.
It seems to me that in this constant
protest and use of shame and all of
that,
that goes along with this,
with this sort of radical movement
towards egalitarianism,
that there's a tremendous amount of
provocation and go on.
I'm going to say this too,
even though I shouldn't,
but it.
But we met her.
I don't believe this,
but I'm trying trying to figure it out.
You know,
I thought it was absolutely comical when
50 shades of gray movie that just.
I just thought that was just so insanely
comical that at the same time there's
this massive political demand for like
radical equality and and say with
regards to sexual behavior and the
fastest selling novel the world had ever
seen was snm domination.
Right?
It's like,
oh,
well we didn't know where the
unconscious is going with that one.
Don't leave.
And sometimes I think like because one
of the things that I've really tried to
puzzle out and it's like I believe this,
right?
I'm just telling you what I've,
where the edges of my thinking have been
going is that you have this crazy
alliance between the feminists and the
radical Islamists that I just do not
get.
It's like the feminist is like why they
aren't protesting nonstop about Saudi
Arabia is just completely beyond me.
Like I do not understand it in the
least.
And I wonder too,
I just wonder bloody wellis this is the
fruit in me is like,
is there an attraction,
you know,
the,
is there an attraction that's emerging
among the female radicals for that
totalitarian male dominance that they've
chased out of the West?
And I mean that's a hell of the thing to
think,
but I am after all,
I am a psychoanalytically minded and I
do think things like that because like I
just can see no rational reason for it.
The only other rational reason is that,
well,
the West needs to fall and so the enemy
of my enemy is,
or the is exactly.
Now what is it the,
I got that wrong.
But the enemy of enemy is my friend.
Yes,
exactly.
Elements tend to vote liberal as well.
Yeah,
as well so that that could be the case,
but I are not going to shake my
suspicion about the this unconscious
balancing because as the demand for
egalitarianism and the eradication of
masculinity accelerates,
there's going to be a longing in the
unconscious for the precise opposite of
that.
Right.
The more you will scream for equality,
the more your unconscious is going to
admire dominance and so.
Well,
that's,
that's well,
that's how you think.
If you're a psychoanalytically minded
and you know,
I'm a great admirer of Freud,
he knew a hell of a lot more than people
like to think and so,
which is partly why everyone still hates
them even though it's been 100 years
since he's really,
really been around.
So.
All right,
we should stop.